[Music]
there's been a controversy last couple
days over a new print ad released by Gap
Kids here's the ad okay after it came
out people became very upset some people
because the only black girl featured in
the ad is being used as an armrest yeah
and a lot of people are not happy about
that now
cut back to me it's a pig here we go you
run that for quite a while I saw those
kids you actually grow up we were on
that so long anyway it's a big
controversy so here to comment is our
good friend Deon Cole
thanks calling in first of all I can't
believe that this is even a story
especially a story causing controversy
put that out up again ok yes the black
girl is clearly being used as armrest
but that type of thing can go both ways
ok I'm sorry just clarify this for me
Deon how does it go both ways I'm glad
you asked owner that's why I'm here
today to introduce my new line of
designer furniture made from 100% white
people first up we have a simple but
elegant Madison coat rack made from
responsibly farm Caucasian materials
adds a touch of class to any home I'm
not sure people are gonna want some
white guy standing around as a hat and
over here we have a stylish yet
functional Cape Cod linen closet made
from all-natural reclaimed white ok I
did I'm curious where do you find these
people there's always plenty of guilty
white people to take Vantage of when
stuff like this comes up I just drive
down a Banana Republic first thing in
the morning and they hop right in the
back of the truck ok I'm just even not
sure it's legal finally my favorite
piece of the collection is a monocle
armchair would match an ottoman
it's the perfect perfect place to sit to
rewatch the first two barbershop movies
before you don't see barbershop the next
cut in theaters everywhere Friday is it
that right autumn oh yeah all right Deon
cool thank you very much
[Applause]
you